i was able to distill certain elements  that helped in creating this sense of  mystery framing is used to hide or  highlight certain elements in this case  a narrow gap between the corners of two  buildings perfectly framed the basilica  de ferrari as i drift through these  alleys i kept coming across these dead  ends initially i'd turn around and  backtrack but on instances when i kept  going i found that it's not a dead end  after all as i moved through these  narrow alleys i kept feeling a constant  pulling it's obviously the narrowness of  the tunnel but also the light at the end  of the alley that created this point of  interest when i followed the light and  reached the end of the tunnel i would  often be pleasantly surprised to find  myself in a light-filled courtyard or an  opening to a canal or anything that  created a feeling of expansion layering  creates anticipation depth and a more  interesting and memorable narrative when  walking through space